de longues heures d'attentes dans le
froid pour venir donner son sang ici à
ni pro nous sommes dans l'un des centres
de don du sang du pays et des files
d'attentes ne désemplissent pas au
troisième jour du conflit entre la
russie et l'ukraine un millier de
personnes viens ici chaque jour pour
venir donner son sang est les quantités
récoltées sont considérables 400 litres
par jour en moyenne les ukrainiens à qui
nous avons parlé nous ont dit qu'ils
voulaient aider leur pays et leur armée
comme il pouvait ici nous pouvons parler
d'un véritable élan national de
solidarité au mans
c'est pour aider les militaires je sais
à 100% que c'est important c'est de
l'aide et du soutien parce qu'ils sont
là et qu'ils ont besoin de notre aide
je vais d'abord donner du sang puis plus
tard je vais m'envoler pour la défense
du territoire
et ensuite je vais voir les occupants
si vous êtes en assez bonne santé vous
devriez faire un don et si vous en avez
l'occasion procurez vous une arme et
partez combattre en première ligne
chacun devrait faire ce qu'il faut
des centres de don du sang comme celui
ci il en existe beaucoup d'encre
l'ukraine ici à bié pro la troisième
plus grande ville du pays les services
médicaux constituent de très grandes
réserves de sang qui seront ensuite
envoyées dans tout le pays là où ce sera
nécessaire